la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue andré rachat pour le groupe
l'est républicain la parole ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce et de l'artisanat
madame la ministre nous vivons
décidément dans une époque faite de
paradoxes
alors que le gouvernement vante d'un
côté la nécessité de la formation et
qu'il dit vouloir relancer
l'apprentissage il envisage semble-t-il
de supprimer certaines qualifications
professionnelles perquis pour les
artisans
il envisage également de restreindre
l'obligation des stages de préparation à
l'installation préalable à la création
d'entreprise il estime ainsi que dans
l'artisanat certains mais qui
n'exigerait aucune qualification grave
erreur s'il en est l'essence même d'un
artisan mes chers collègues la patrie
est la pâte la pratique a pa ta pratique
d'un savoir faire qui ne s'improvise pas
l'artisanat selon ce sont des centaines
de milliers d'emplois hautement
qualifiés et ces qualifications sont des
gages de compétences de qualité et de
sérieux
les bras des voies relient supprimer
ouvrirait la porte à une sorte de
secteur informel constitué non plus de
chefs d'entreprises mais de tâcheron
dont le consommateur serait le premier à
pâtir avec un service à minima et
naturellement de moindre qualité
de même en matière d'installation les
sages préparatoire non plus à faire la
preuve de leur nécessité revenir sur
leur caractère obligatoire dans nombre
de cas reviendrait à vouloir mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs malgré toute
l'énergie qu'une personne peut montrer
au début sur l'entreprise
elle ne peut naturellement pas démarrer
son activité sans disposer les
informations et conseils nécessaires à
la bonne gestion de fait ces stages
obligatoires ont permis d'éviter
beaucoup de catastrophes dès lors madame
la ministre est il exact que vous
envisagez de vous engager dans ces voies
destructrice de tout un secteur
économique de notre pays
alors que tous les représentants des
activités concernées revendique au
contraire pour elle toujours plus
d'ambition depuis des années pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame martine
pinville secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'artisanat du commerce de la
consommation vous avez la parole
menés merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur je ne peux à aucun
moment vous laisser dire qu'on
souhaiterait remettre en cause les
qualifications et la formation des
artisans gens rencontrent tous les jours
tous les jours j'ai contact avec ses
artisans avec la qualité du travail
qu'ils peuvent mener mais on peut
constater
monsieur le sénateur que les dispositifs
qui sont applicables
aujourd'hui sont quelquefois d'une
immense complexité et qu'il est parfois
ils sont parfois éloignée de l'objectif
premier
quel la protection du consommateur et sa
sécurité
et je prendrai l'exemple puisque vous
citez vous citez les artisans vous citer
tous ceux qui peuvent qui souhaitent
s'installer et qui on exerce une
profession et de très beaux métiers
je prendrai l'exemple des restaurateurs
les restaurateurs par exemple pour
pouvoir s'installer n'ont pas
nécessairement besoin d'une
qualification
je parle bien là de la création la
création d'entreprises et la création
d'emplois est bien là ils n'ont pas
besoin mais il est bien évidemment
nécessaire qu'ils aient une active une
qualification pour exercer leur métier
alors voilà ne nous ne nous tromper pas
ne vous y trompez pas monsieur le le
sénateur et puis vous m'interrogez
également sur les stages préparatoires à
l'installation
vous savez là aussi monsieur le sénateur
lors de de l'installation du chou et
d'installation d'un certain nombre de
deux citoyens et bien elles ont des
difficultés notamment quant au délai qui
peut leur être proposées pour mettre en
place pour faire ce stage d'installation
et qu'également ce coût est important
trop importants souvent donc nous devons
là aussi avancé et nous avons contact
avec les organisations professionnelles
pour continuer la discussion et les
échanges merci pour dix secondes
monsieur richard davies je note que a
priori vous n'avez pas l'intention
mettre en péril ces qualifications tant
mieux ce que nous voulons c'est un
artisanat force n'est pas un artisanat
tirés vers le bas et ça passe par des
vraies entreprises qui mettent en oeuvre
des métiers que le chef d'entreprise et
les collaborateurs savent maîtriser
merci